hi it's michelle from laplace and beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
lipstick wearer
a lot of you have been asking me to talk
more about the science behind makeup
products and a lot of people have been
asking me what lipstick i've been
wearing
so i decided to combine the two in this
video if you like nerding out about the
science behind beauty products
give this video a like subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos
so today i thought i'd talk a little bit
about lipstick science so what goes into
a lipstick
i'm going to be talking about the
ingredients that go into a lipstick and
the science behind how they make it
work first let's talk about what her
lipstick is i mean we all know what a
lipstick is but
let's break it down further lipsticks
are solid sticks that you drag across
your skin and they leave behind a thin
layer of color
that means that if you really narrow
down to the very basics a lipstick has
to be
solid at room temperature hard enough
not to break when you apply some
pressure to it
soft enough that'll leave behind a layer
when you drag it across your skin
and that layer has to stay even for a
while even though your lips are one of
the places on your face that moves
around the most
and it encounters lots of water so
here's what we have in the lipstick to
make this all happen
there's a lot of variation with
different brands different types of
lipsticks different finishes
but i had to commit to a percentage to
make this diagram so this is just
representative
most of the lipstick is made up of oily
substances like waxes waxy paste
and oils this is sometimes called the
base of the lipstick and has to strike a
good balance between being hard enough
not to break
and soft enough to leave a nice layer on
your lips without too much effort
these oily substances are very water
repellent or hydrophobic
which is important because your lips
encounter lots of water from drinking
and from your spit
the more solid ingredients in a lipstick
are usually waxes
they're sometimes called structuring
agents and they're what gives
a lipstick its solid structure some of
the really common solid wax ingredients
that you'll see
are canoe wax candelilla wax beeswax
microcrystalline wax and ozorite
these all have really high melting
points above 60 degrees or 140 degrees
fahrenheit
and these keep your lipsticks mostly
solid even when they're on your lips or
in a not too hot handbag
generally the more wax you have in a
lipstick the harder it will be
then you have the oils and waxy pastes
these are soft at room temperature and
so they'll soften the overall lipstick
so that it'll actually apply
a lot of these are also emollient
moisturizers so they'll keep your lips
soft and moisturized there is a massive
range of ingredients that different
lipsticks use for this
you have plant oils like castor oil
butters like shea butter
fatty esters like isosterol isosturate
hydrocarbon based ingredients like
polybutine
and mineral oil and silicones like
phenol trimethicone
oils also give a shiny finish and so
matte lipsticks tend to have a bit less
of these
this is why matte lipsticks often have
this reputation of being really drying
and sucking all the moisture out of your
lips
but the fact that they have less oils
also means that they tend to last longer
on your lips
so they form a harder layer that doesn't
move around and slip around so much
an important aspect of the base is that
to get a smooth lipstick it has to dry
into small microscopic crystals not
larger chunky ones
so this means the lipstick applies more
smoothly and also it's less prone to
breaking because
a small layer of the lipstick can be
left behind without breaking off
a large chunk if you have a grainy
textured lipstick this is usually
because the base isn't a great blend
another issue that you might see if you
have a bad base mixture is
sweating this is when you see droplets
on the surface of the lipstick and
usually it's because some of the
ingredients in the base
aren't playing well together and so some
of the oil gets squeezed out
sometimes this happens in hot weather
because the lipstick melts a bit and
then re-solidifies
and that process squeezes more oil out
then we have the pigment which is what
gives a lipstick its color
one of the important things about
lipstick is that it is on your mouth
which means that it's one of the few
cosmetic products that we will actually
end up eating
quite a bit of not as much as
fear-mongering places would have you
believe
but you do end up eating quite a bit of
it that's the reason why some pigments
aren't allowed in lip products at all or
they're only allowed at certain
concentrations
the color pigment is dispersed in the
base
this means that it doesn't dissolve in
the base but it's ground up into tiny
microscopic pieces that are spread out
evenly in the base and so it looks like
it's one continuous color
it's sort of like protein powder and a
protein shake but blended really really
well
you get a much nicer looking lipstick if
the pigments are ground up really finely
and spread out really evenly in the base
the color additives in a lipstick are
usually in that
final section of an ingredients list
that says may contain
usually in a lipstick range the lipstick
base stays the same and it's just the
pigments that change
that's why you usually don't see a range
of lipsticks that have both matte and
shiny finishes but you
usually see a range that has the same
finish and different colors in there
it's relatively easy to change the
pigments in a lipstick around but if you
want to change the finish you have to
change the oils
and that means you have to re-jig the
whole base and this is a lot more effort
there are lots of different pigments
that you'll see in lipsticks these are
things like
inorganic colors like iron oxide organic
colors and their lake versions which
have names like red seven or red seven
late
there's also carmine which comes from
crushed beetles you'll see white
pigments as well like zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide
these make your lipstick more opaque and
so it hides your underlying lip color
and so when you put it on your lips
it looks more like the color in the tube
rather than your lips plus the color in
the tube
there are also effect pigments and
lipsticks and this is how you get a
glittery or shimmery or pearl or matte
finish
for shimmery effects lipsticks use
larger particles than your color
pigments would be
so these are things like mica bismuth
oxychloride and pearl
these are usually added near the end of
the lipstick making process
so you don't end up mixing it too much
and smashing it up
and not having these big flecks anymore
with matte lipstick sometimes there's
still a bit too much oil for it to look
properly matte
and so there'll be something added like
silica or clay on top of that you want
the lipstick to stay good for longer and
so you have preservatives and
antioxidants
lipsticks are generally easier to
preserve than other cosmetic products
because they don't contain water
they're very oil-based and so that makes
it a lot harder for mold and bacteria to
get a foothold
so usually it's just the surface of the
lipstick that's a bit of a worry and so
preservatives like parabens and
phenoxyethanol are added to stop
bacteria mold growing on the surface
but the big problem with oils and
butters is that they tend to go rancid
when they're exposed to oxygen for too
long
and so antioxidants slow this from
happening you'll see things like vitamin
e
bha and bht but the oils and waxes in
the base can still go rancid because if
you think about the lifetime of the
lipstick it's relatively long
and oils and waxes on their own do
already sort of smell a bit funny and
taste a bit funny like we don't
go around drinking oil for a reason and
so to hide this funny taste and funny
smell
we have flavors and fragrances in there
as well there are other optional
ingredients in there as well
things like sunscreen actives to give
your lips some sun protection
and also active ingredients like in skin
care this is just a basic overview there
are lots of other little things
that might come up when you're trying to
optimize a lipstick formula the listing
might stick to the mold when it's being
made
and so you might need to add something
that helps it shrink a little bit as it
hardens and so that unsticks it from the
mold
you might also need pigment disperses to
make the color more even
[Music]
so the other question is what lipstick
am i wearing
the lipstick i'm wearing when people
usually ask me about what lipstick i'm
wearing
is this one it's a pretty old lipstick
from teas cosmetics
it's from e's ready to wear collection
and it's called classy caramel
this is a really pretty brick color it's
super moisturizing and it glides on
really well
it's been discontinued for a long time
and i know it's kind of gross
but i still use it but in my defense
this is based on ingredients that don't
go rancid easily
there are lots of hydrocarbons which are
very i guess
unnatural and on the bright side it
means that it lasts for ages without
having serious rancidity
or micro problems the other reason i'm
still using it
is because it's really hard to find a
really moisturizing lipstick
and it's really hard to find this sort
of brick color anymore apparently a lot
of lipstick brands have been
discontinuing brick colors because
they're a bit dated and 90s but
i think it looks really good i not
really good at following trends
but from the fact that everyone's been
asking me about it
i think the demand is still there so
please can we have some more
so in the interest of recommending a
lipstick that other people could get
and the fact that i should probably
replace it
i went around to a whole bunch of stores
to try to find a dupe
i think i might have swatched like a
hundred lipsticks that look like they
could be a dupe
but i only managed to find two
conveniently one is
kinda high-end and one is
budget-friendly the first one is
becca ultimate lipstick love in rouge
this is a really nice creamy opaque
formula and it comes in a really nice
luxe tube which gives a satisfying
sound when you open it and it clicks in
nicely with a magnet
this is a bit less moisturizing and
doesn't apply as smoothly but it's
really pigmented and leaves a pretty
even stain
after it wears off
the other lipstick that match really
well is revlon super lustrous lipstick
in
extra spicy revlon are my favorite
drugstore lipstick brand i just find
that the formulas are really nice
and really even and they're just really
easy to use
this is more moisturizing than the becca
lipstick but less pigmented
it's sort of in between the becca and
t's lipsticks
these aren't quite as moisturizing and
glossy as the teas cosmetics one
so sometimes when i wear them i put on
an extra glossier lipstick on top
i've been using revlon super lustrous
glass shine in rum raisin
this is a really moisturizing lipstick
it's almost like a lip balm
but the color isn't quite as intense and
so if i'm trying to go for a more opaque
lipstick look
i lay that on top of something else on
its own it's really good for casual wear
if you just want something that gives a
bit of color without being
a full lipstick it's a lot like revlon's
discontinued lip butters
some of the sales assistants recommended
that i go to mac because mac tends to do
nice 90 colors
but they didn't actually have a good
match mac chili is the same color but
matte and so that doesn't give the same
sort of finish the same sort of easy
application
as my teas cosmetics one we did find
that using good form over
auburn lipliner gave the same sort of
effect but i prefer
a more all-in-one lipstick that's easy
to reapply so i guess i'm still looking
for the perfect dupe of this lipstick
if you have any suggestions leave them
in the comments and i'll try to track
them down and compare them
i hope you like this video it's a little
bit different from the usual skin care
content but i hope it was still really
interesting
click the like subscribe check me out on
instagram and check out my blog if you
like nerding out about beauty
and i'll see you next time for more
beauty science
you